eigentlich meine damen und herren wollte
ich sie heute begrüßen mit den worten
die ganze welt blickt in die türkei doch
verdient haben ist alles anders
die usa haben einen
nationalkonservativen präsidenten
gewählt und die sehnsucht nach einer
autoritären führung scheint definitiv im
trend davon erzählen trumps aufstieg in
amerika putin russlands die etablierung
rechtspopulistischer parteien in vielen
europäischen ländern ebenso wie die
harte politik von präsident erdogan in
der türkei und ich frage mich drehen wir
gerade das rad zurück in zeiten die wir
längst überwunden glaubten
und was heißt das für die politik wenn
tatsachen durch lügen ersetzt werden und
die bessere story den sieger kürt ich
freue mich sehr diese fragen jetzt hier
am gottlieb duttweiler institute in
rüschlikon mit zwei wunderbaren gästen
diskutieren zu dürfen
mit eric schaaf sie ist autorin
vermutlich die meistgelesene autor in
zurzeit in der türkei auch hierzulande
eine bestseller-autorin und sie
verknüpft ihre literatur mit einer
messerscharfen analyse der gesellschafts
politischen verhältnisse in der türkei
herzlich willkommen und mit malcolm cola
catan religionspädagogin und
politikwissenschaftlerin und ja zurzeit
eine gastprofessur an der universität
zürich inne
auch innen herzlich willkommen schön
dass sie beide hier sind fragt die usa
haben gewählt dann kramt zum fünfzigsten
präsidenten haben sie damit gerechnet
oder hat wieder vollkommen überrascht
ich war sehr traurig aber nicht sehr
überrascht weil ich davon ausging dass
es ein sehr enges rennen geben würde
in anbetracht zunahme des populismus und
zahlreicher weiterer faktoren in den usa
und weltweit
dabei geht es nicht nur um trump
wir müssen den ganzen diskurs den er
entfesselt
28 überall in der welt
jump ist kein isolierter faktor weltweit
haben wir eine zunahme von populismus
nationalismus religiösem
fundamentalismus fremdenfeindlichkeit
wird viel furcht vor dem anderen vor
menschen die anders sind und viel angst
jene menschen die diesen nationalismus
nicht teilen müssen wege finden wie sie
mit diesen andersdenkenden ins gespräch
kommen
so senkte fremd wenn wir nicht
kommunizieren können wird es noch viel
schlimmer
also müssen wir verstehen woher diese
angst kommt wir können die furcht und
ängste der menschen nicht kleinreden
wir müssen vielmehr ein besseres
narrativ anbieten ein besseres gegner
hat ihre battleground erneuert über all
diese themen werden die heute sprechen
frau kollabiert an
ich war ja sehr auffallend dass beim
jump seine reden von ganzen wahlkampf
gespickt hat mit islamophoben parolen
dennoch war präsident erdogan einer der
ersten der donald trump gratuliert hat
zum wahlerfolg
wie hat man sich das also ich denke das
muss man im gesamtzusammenhang sehen
erstens waren außer dem türkischen
staatspräsidenten jacob also noch andere
die ihm sehr rasch gratulierten dass es
das eine das andere ist dass den
türkischen staatspräsidenten adern und
donald trump eine wirtschaftliche
beziehung in der türkei verbindet es
gibt in istanbul
die beiden trump tower hat trump
investiert und diese sind erst vor
einigen wenigen jahren eröffnet worden
erdogan hat hier im juni 2016 also
dieses jahr noch mal erklärt dass er
tatsächlich darüber nachdenkt oder es
eben vorschlug diese traumtors
umzubenennen in einen anderen namen und
hat hier als argument angebracht dass
eben donald trump sich islamfeindlich
muslim feindlich geäußert hatte und dass
seine beweggründe gewesen sind diese
namen überdenken eine neue namens
überlegung anzubringen
allerding vereint diese beiden politiker
also jetzt schon als politiker als neuer
politiker sehr vieles in ihrem
politikstil der sehr autoritär geprägt
ist der teil
wieso glühen geprägt ist vor allem in
der sprache in der körperhaltung der
marginalisieren wirkt in den narrativen
also marginalisieren gegenüber
sogenannten andersdenkenden
das ist schwierig dieser begriff finde
ich weil er zusätzlich marginalisiert
also hier entscheiden einige wenige und
vor allem zwei sehr starke
charismatische persönlichkeiten darüber
wer dazugehörig ist doch nicht
ich würde aber in der tat die globale
entwicklung auch die entwicklung in
europa hiermit voranstellen so wir haben
hier einen sommer erlebt vor allem in
ungarn als auch in deutschland der sehr
stark über die sehr aktive verlaufen ist
und jetzt zusätzlich über wieso bühne
aspekte gender aspekte noch mal
verstärkt wird sie haben jetzt beide
eigentlich deutlich gemacht dass es um
tendenzen geht oder sich das
wahlergebnis auch tendenzen freilegt die
in anderen ländern sehen natürlich in
vielen europäischen ländern denken wir
gerade er daran was mit dem wechsel
passiert ist wo nicht so langer zeit
denken wir an die niederlande denken an
frankreich deutschland aber eben auch
tendenzen die sich in der türkei
manifestieren haben denn diese sagen wir
mal national konservativen strömungen
alle wirklich etwas miteinander zu tun
oder irgendwie ähnliche quellen kann man
das über einen leisten schlagen frau
stephanie connection ich glaube wir
müssen die verbindung und klar erkennen
ist
wir sind viel zu sehr globalisiert
ob es uns gefällt oder nicht wir alle
sind globalisiert miteinander verbunden
was in einem teil der welt geschieht
wirkt sich auf das geschehen in einem
anderen teil der welt aus extremismus an
einem ort schafft mehr extremismus an
einem anderen ort ultra nationalismus an
einem ort schafft anderswo mehr
ultranationalist demokraten müssen diese
zusammenhänge erkennen und wir müssen
zusammenarbeiten wir alle sitzen
gemeinsam in diesem boot als weltbürger
und was wir in der türkei gelernt haben
wir müssen einsehen dass die rechte die
wir für selbstverständlich halten sehr
schnell verloren gehen können länder
können leicht zurückfallen
die zeit bewegt sich nicht zwingend
immer vorwärts manchmal geht sie
rückwärts
manchmal dreht sie kreise und wenn wir
nicht aus den fehlern der vergangenheit
lernen sind wir dazu verdammt immer und
immer wieder die gleichen fehler zu
begehen diese dinge machen mir sorgen
welchen fehlern wäre denn jetzt gerade
zu lernen
ich nenne es stammesdenken die idee dass
wir alle zu stemmen gehören dass wir
alle in unsere kleinen
stammesgesellschaften zurück müssen
das ist ein trugschluss und zwar ein
sehr gefährlicher trugschluss
die extreme rechte sowie konservative
oder autoritäre politiker sagen uns dass
wir sichere sind wenn wir alle in
unseren eigenen kleinen
stammesgesellschaften leben
sie erzählen uns gleichartigkeit bringe
sicherheit
das ist eine illusion so etwas ist nicht
möglich
dafür sind wir viel zu globalisiert die
lösung liegt nicht darin mauern zu
errichten und länder auszuschließen
das macht langfristig alles nur noch
schlimmer stattdessen müssen wir vor
allem das vertrauen der menschen in die
demokratie kultivieren und erneuern
mir macht die zunahme von liberalen
demokratien große sorgen
in polen in ungarn in der türkei land
umland sehen wir wie autoritäre
regierungen mit hilfe demokratischer
instrumente an die macht kommen dann
aber andere stimmen unterdrücken für
mich ist demokratie mehr als bloß der
entscheid an der wahlurne
das ist nur eine voraussetzung für
demokratie damit echte demokratie
möglich ist braucht es zusätzlich zur
wahlurne auch rechtssicherheit
gewaltentrennung redefreiheit
frauenrechte rechte für homosexuelle und
transgender das alles gehört zu einer
demokratie
es könnte man ja sagen in allem was ich
ihm zustehende gibt es trotzdem auch die
moment wo man vielleicht skepsis zeiten
naja das ist aber ja dann doch nicht
ganz die gleiche situation in der türkei
wie jetzt in vielen anderen ländern also
also die dinge die sie jetzt aufgezählt
haben wir natürlich viele länder in
europa zb nach wie vor sagen auch in den
usa das haben wir natürlich wir haben
natürlich diese zb trennung
gewaltentrennung wir haben die gewisse
garantie von menschenrechten und genau
das ist in der türkei nicht mehr
garantiert oder war zum teil noch nie
garantiert aber wie weit reicht die
parallele wirklich also ich denke dass
hier betont werden muss dass die
gesetzesgrundlagen in der türkei
mitnichten der politik die umgesetzt
wird entsprechen die gesetzesgrundlagen
sind so gestaltet dass sie sehr wohl
wenn wir die uns die verfassung auch
wenn sie eine reform benötigt
wenn wir uns die verfassung hier ansehen
dass hier das prinzip zum säkularismus
zur freiheitlichen demokratie zur
meinungsfreiheit zur pressefreiheit
fixiert ist und dass das dass die
verfassung die türkische entsprechend
ausgelegt ist was sie aber beobachten
ist eine hohe akzeptanz an autoritären
und auch chauvinistischen politik stilen
und führungsstilen die die stimmen der
oder innerhalb der zivilbevölkerung
scheinbar erstickt es ist in der türkei
nach wie vor so dass die
zivilbevölkerung sehr stark ist
wir sind momentan damit konfrontiert das
über 370 organisationen und vereinen
allein in den letzten tagen verboten
oder geschlossen worden sind unter
diesen vereinen sind etliche
frauenorganisation
in frauenorganisationen die frauen
kindern schutz bieten die sich hier
politisch sehr sehr stark machen und
immer noch ihre stimmen erheben gegen
diese form der eingriffe gegen diese
form der verbote was im moment ja
passierten der türkei ist in der tat
extrem erschreckend dass man muss von
waren säuberungsaktionen sprechen eine
freie presse scheint es nicht mehr zu
geben hat sich denn das angekündigt frau
schwach sind dass sie sie bewegungen die
sie absehen konnten was hängen in ca we
have been sitting back leider sind wir
in der türkei zurück gerutscht
das geschieht sehr schnell das geschieht
mit einem irritierenden tempel viele von
uns sind sehr deprimiert wir sind sehr
demoralisieren die liberalen demokraten
der türkei fühlen sich sehr einsam und
allein gelassen dass sie damit leben wir
schon lange
was aber jetzt geschieht ist noch die
premiere in my mind für mich steht fest
was im juli geschah
der versuchte staatsstreich war sehr
sehr falsch ich kritisiere das offen und
heftig weil ich an die demokratie
glauben wir wollen keine militärputsches
mehr oder irgend etwas in dieser art
aber die anschließende säuberungsaktion
ist ebenfalls falsch weil so viele leute
davon betroffen sind und hat den effekt
im moment stehen journalisten autoren
intellektuelle wissenschaftler
frauenorganisationen kinder
organisationen unter großem druck
leute die nichts mit gewalt in
irgendeiner form zu tun haben werden in
den gleichen topf geworfen
ich finde das sehr gefährlich und
ungesund wie für eine echte lebendige
demokratie braucht es vielfalt und ich
bin sehr traurig dass wir in der türkei
die vielfalt nicht leben
wir zelebrieren kein weltbürger 2 wir
haben das immer als problem gesehen das
ist schade
denn ich bin der meinung dass die türkei
durch das aufgeben ihres kosmopolitismus
viel verloren hat ich glaube sehr
starker die bedeutung von vielfalt und
weltbürgertum als ergänzung der
demokraten
was würde das die sie heißen die lavid
und kosmopolitismus zu feiern oder zu
leben hätten wir in unserem leben
irgendetwas lernen dann von menschen die
anders sind als wir selber jemand der
genau so ist wie ich ist bloß ein echo
meiner stimme und ich bin sein
gleichartigkeit erzeugt nur echos wenn
aber leute zusammenkommen die
verschieden sehen die sich kulturell
voneinander unterscheiden
ethnisch intellektuell dann können wir
uns gegenseitig herausfordern
vielfalt ist ein schatz etwas kostbares
das problem ist dass wir weltweit einen
trend haben der vielfalt nicht schätzt
im gegenteil man will gleichartigkeit
eine ideologie des gleichförmigen und
des nationalismus in der 1900 fünfziger
und sechziger jahren dachten viele
intellektuelle der nationalismus würde
verschwinden religiöser fundamentalismus
würde verschwinden
das war nicht der fall ist genau das
gegenteil passiert jetzt
wir müssen aber alle begreifen ja einer
von uns ist deutsch der andere türkisch
gleichzeitig sind wir aber alle
weltbürger bin fast sicher frau klettert
an dass sie das alles unterschreiben
würden aber aus politik theoretikerin
wie reagieren sie darauf tatsächlich ist
es ja so dass sehr viele eigentlich so
denken gerade auch in den medien wurde
viel in diese richtung geschrieben die
frau stockes beschreibt aber es ist
offenbar nicht das was die menschen da
draußen begeistert oder zumindest ein
bisschen mehr wie die hälfte lässt sich
davon im moment nicht begeistern
ja und nein also ich würde
hier in einem anderen punkt in einem
strukturellen punkt tatsächlich ansetzen
und zwar an dem punkt dass die
einschränkungen der
presseberichterstattung der
künstlerischen freiheit oder der
freiheiten
bereits ab dem jahr 2008 2009 vor allem
dann ab 2011 merklich oder spürbar in
der türkei los gingen oder losgegangen
sind und hier sehr viele akademiker
akademikerin wissenschaftler
journalisten journalistinnen aber vor
allem künstler in ihrem schaffen
eingeschränkt wurden
dies wurde so vermittelt auch in den
medien dass es sich hier um eine
lediglich kleine gruppe handeln würde
wobei natürlich die einschränkungen
dieser berufsfelder und dieser
präsentationen einen rückschluss darüber
geben was noch mehr möglich ist und was
in zukunft auch möglich sein könnte mit
einer politisch forcierten zensur mit
der einschränkung freiheitlicher rechte
der pressefreiheit und auch der
medienfreiheit in dem die grundlage also
die rechtsstaatliche grundlage mehr und
mehr entzogen wird
das andere ist dass hier im zuge der
letzten jahre also trotz der weit
fortgeschrittenen globalisierung trotz
eigentlich der kommunikations nähe die
wir ja auch haben über viele soziale
medien über eine räumlich empfundenen
idee die wir auch besitzen türkische
native revitalisiert werden ethnische
ethnisch konzentrierte native
revitalisiert werden und wieder lebendig
gemacht werden um sich quasi abzugrenzen
von denjenigen die freiheit und
demokratie sehr wohl nicht als
selbstläufer begreifen oder hier die
potenzielle gefahr sehen wenn es denn
heute den einen trifft trifft ist auch
den anderen und den flächenbrand ja auch
rechtzeitig erkannt
lassen sie uns über diese negative
gleich nachher sprechen aber noch mal
kurz bei der türkei bleiben
die frauschaft wurden ja selber schon
einmal angeklagt werden wegen der
absetzung des türkentums wie das damals
hieß 2006 wegen eines buches ein buch
der bastard von istanbul in dem eine
romanfigur eigentlich über den genozid
an den armeniern spricht sie wurden
mangels beweisen freigesprochen oder das
verfahren wurde fallen gelassen aber in
dieser zeit waren damals auch schwanger
mussten die furchtbare dinge erleben sie
wurden bespuckt ihr bild wurde bespuckte
bild wurde auch verbrannt zusammen mit
der flagge beispielsweise der eu
wenn sie daran zurückdenken war in
dieser zeit für sie trotzdem die türkei
ihre heimat hatten sie einen bezug zu
diesem land der sie auch irgendwie noch
begeistert hat so much love in my heart
die menschen in der türkei liegen mit
soße am hebbel menschen jeglicher
herkunft die kultur die geschichte die
kunst die literatur
wenn ich die menschen anschaue fühle ich
mich stets optimistisch aber ich bin
sehr pessimistisch wenn ich die
türkischen politiker und die politik der
türkei betrachtet weil sie äußerst
aggressiv ist spaltend und sehr männer
betont und ich glaube für autoren wird
es zunehmend schwierig ihre meinungen zu
äußern
insbesondere für journalisten aber auch
für akademiker die redefreiheit in der
türkei wurde im lauf der jahre zunehmend
unterdrückt und jetzt ist es noch
schlimmer
ich glaube heute weiß jeder journalist
jeder schriftsteller wieder dichter in
der türkei das uns worte in
schwierigkeiten bringen kann sehr
schnell in den sozialen medien können
sie gewünscht von regierungsfreundlichen
zeitungen über nacht verteufelt werden
man kann sich vor gericht ziehen oder
ausweisen wegen eines tweets eines
gedichts oder eines artikels den sie
geschrieben haben
witten frau köhler dann haben sie schon
ähnliche erfahrungen gemacht oder können
sie frei reisen sie äußern sich auch
zunehmend politisch in verschiedenen
tageszeitungen und haben einen großteil
ihrer verwandtschaft in izmir
ich denke dass es für mich im moment
äußerst schwierig ist weil ich in den
letzten jahren kritische artikel
verfasst habe kritische artikel vor
allem dass die frauenpolitik betrifft
was die politik gegenüber arbeitnehmern
arbeitnehmerinnen betrifft in der türkei
und insgesamt das den politikstil
betrifft und dem missbrauch des islams
also einen islam ohne islam im grunde
genommen der in der politik in der
türkei sichtbar ist über autoritäre
demonstrationen über eine sehr
autoritäre und paternalistische sprache
dies dass ein islam unis lahm weil hier
aspekte aus dem islam aus der tradition
des islams felix selektiv herausgepickt
werden und verpackt werden in
anforderungen bzw forderungen gegenüber
der bevölkerung also wenn wir
beispielsweise an die zielsetzung 2023
denken die die jetzige regierungspartei
entworfen hat im jahr 2023 feiert die
türkei ihr 100 jähriges jubiläum und
diese zielsetzung 2023 bedeutet dass die
jetzige regierende partei versuchen wird
alles versuchen wird bis einschließlich
des jahres 2023 und darüber hinaus an
der macht zu bleiben
was bedeutet dass das bedeutet dass hier
eine politische elite davon ausgeht
nicht abgewählt zu werden und hier davon
ausgeht dass die wahlbevölkerung sich
nicht anders entscheiden kann oder keine
andere partei in das türkische parlament
im sprung schaffen könnte
das ist ein antidemokratisches stellen
element als ein element das nicht
freiheitlich verstandenen demokratie
entspricht das ist das eine und in
diesem konzept ziel 2023 sind sehr stark
die elemente sichtbar die sich zwar zum
islam zuordnen lassen aber verpackt
werden beispielsweise in wirtschaftliche
ziele beispielsweise in eine völkische
sprache in eine überführung der
türkischen identität in eine überführung
der muslimische sunnitischen identität
indem alle anderen islamischen
ausrichtungen muslimischen identitäten
teile des islams ausgeschlossen werden
jetzt sind wir wieder bei diesen
narrativen die sie schon einmal erwähnt
haben und die sie auch aufgebracht haben
frau scharf ab das ist ja tatsächlich
was sehr interessant dass dass man sagt
wir leben in einer zeit eigentlich dass
das oft faktischen es zählen nicht mehr
die fakten ist halt nicht mehr der
bezugnahme auf bestimmte überprüfbare
statistisch erwiesen fakten
beispielsweise zählt auch nicht mehr die
redlichkeit dass man nachweisen kann
woher man sein wissen hat wie man es
eingebettet hat wovon es abhängt sondern
primär die gute story die gute
geschichte das narrativ mit dem man so
massen begeistern kann
sie sind eine schriftstellerin sie
prägen narrativen frau und wenn ich ihre
literatur lese habe ich das gefühl
gerade auch wieder hier der geruch des
paradieses ihre narrativ ist eigentlich
das ringen um eine pluralistische
gesellschaft das ringen um eine
tolerante gesellschaft auch warum lässt
sich mit diesem narrativ keine politik
machen im moment
ich verstehe die macht der worte
ich verstehe auch die angst der menschen
ich bin selber eine ängstliche person
und würde nie die ängste anderer
menschen kleinreden ein fehler den die
linke wie auch die liberalen gemacht
haben
sowohl in großbritannien wie in den usa
und vielleicht bis zu einem gewissen
grad auch in der türkei sie haben die
ängste der leute nicht verstanden
wir müssen verstehen warum die leute
angst
weshalb sie sich sorgen um die zukunft
machen und dann mit ihnen verbindung
aufnehmen und einen besseren ansatz
finden ein feind bachelor einen
humanistischen umfassenderen ansatz das
geht wir können das das problem aber ist
um auf das beispiel der türkei zurück zu
kommen
die gesellschaft in der türkei leidet
unter kollektivem gedächtnisschwund
unsere beziehung zur vergangenheit ist
voller brüche
viele leute wissen kaum etwas über die
geschichte
sie interessieren sich nicht dafür auf
der basis dieser amnesie ist es für die
regierungen sehr einfach träume einer
goldenen vergangenheit
heraufzubeschwören barta golden passt
das ist eine entwicklung die um die welt
gilt
das geschieht in russland in der türkei
jetzt in den usa bei diesem neuen trend
geht es um die rückkehr in ein goldenes
zeitalter von einstiger größe
das ist eine illusion
dies ist die illusion die sie uns
verkaufen in der türkei haben wir jetzt
diese nähe osmanischen träume manchmal
prägen diesen eher osmanischen träume
sogar die außenpolitik ich finde das
sehr gefährlich sagte jump in den usa
während der ganzen kampagne
er sprach davon amerika wieder groß zu
machen
es ist immer dieser wunsch zurückzugehen
zu einer illusion in eine vorgestellte
vergangenheit die sie versuchen zu
propagieren
da der wir müssen auf das jetzt
fokussieren wir müssen erinnerungen wach
halten aber gleichzeitig ein viel
besseres gegen rappi finden das ist
möglich interessant finde ich als sie
haben das bereits erwähnte frau kohler
catan dieses ziel 20 23 von präsident
erdogan und der akp kann man sich auch
angucken auf youtube gibt von werbespot
hennef 20 23 da sieht man sehr stark
dass zu diesem traum sehr stark
wirtschaftliche interessen dazu gehören
und die erste rede eigentlich vom tram
nach der wahl
die bestand ja auch darin primär zu
sagen wir werden die größte
volkswirtschaft aller zeiten sein wir
werden unser wirtschaft
wachstum verdoppeln präsident erdogan
sagt in den entsprechenden werbespot
werden zu den zehn größten
volkswirtschaften der welt gehören
inwiefern ist eigentlich für dieses
narrativ überhaupt sagen das
nationalkonservative wirklich so wichtig
und inwiefern geht es primär darum den
eindruck zu haben wir wollen auch ein
stück vom kuchen rein was den
materiellen reichtum anbelangt im grund
genommen wird hier eine ideal
gesellschaft entworfen jetzt völlig
unabhängig von den politischen
zielsetzungen die hier beschrieben
werden es wird ein ideal entworfen eine
ideale gemeinschaft die strebsam ist die
arbeit die im sinne der nation arbeitet
denkt und ihre ziele setzt und hier
kommen selbstverständlich
wirtschaftliche aspekte ins spiel indem
diese ökonomischen kriterien stabilität
versprechen in der türkei
wenn wir uns daran zurück erinnern ist
die jetzige regierende partei die akp an
die macht kommt 2002 zu einer zeit die
sehr sehr stark von korruption geprägt
gewesen ist sehr stark geprägt gewesen
ist von einer wirtschaftlichen
instabilität von aspekten die man
durchaus so beschreiben kann das in die
parteien überhaupt kein vertrauen mehr
vorhanden gewesen ist und diese total
hat es geschafft 2002 sofort was die
mehrheit zu erlangen unter anderem eben
auch mit dem versprechen von
wirtschaftlicher stabilität und das hat
lange funktioniert das ist das eine das
andere ist dass hier die nationale
stärke sehr fokussiert wird über die
wirtschaftliche leistung also das
leistungsprinzip steht im vordergrund
auch der nationalismus steht hier im
vordergrund nationalismus und
wirtschaftliche leistung versprechen
hier stabilität und eine ruhige
gesellschaft in der man in frieden leben
kann aber dass ich wieder beschrieben
sozusagen von der regierung aus und ich
habe sie so verstanden fragt dass sie
auch ich reden haben was wollen einig
die mensch
wovon träumen die menschen und das würde
mich auch interessieren also wenn man
ziele formuliert für eine gesellschaft
dieses dieses dieser traum amerika
wieder groß zu machen das soll ja auch
die menschen ansprechen wovon träumen
denn die türken wenn ich das mal so ganz
pauschal sagen darf
ich glaube wir dürfen nicht vergessen
dass die türkei ein sehr kompliziertes
vielschichtiges land ist leider auch
eine sehr gespaltene gesellschaft sie
ist stark polarisiert und erbittert
politisiert was ich sehr ungesund finde
wir sollten aber nicht den fehler machen
die akp regierung mit der gesamten
türkischen gesellschaft gleichzusetzen
in der türkei gibt es eine
zivilgesellschaft sie ist sehr
vielschichtig und wenn ich an die kurden
denke die aleviten an junge frauen
wir haben fantastische frauen jeglicher
herkunft da gibt es auch viel widerstand
aber wenn ich auf ihre vorherige frage
zurückkommen darf
für mich als türkin war es sehr spannend
in england ich reise oft in die türkei
aber ich lebe vor allem in england
während der zeit des referendums der brh
exit kampagne
sie haben erwähnt die tatsachen
manipuliert werden in england gab es
diese plakate
das werde ich nie vergessen darauf stand
die türken kommen darunter 80 millionen
von ihnen kommen in die eu deshalb ist
es für uns an der zeit die eu zu
verlassen
natürlich wusste die lief kampagne in
england sehr genau dass sich die türkei
nächster zeit nicht der eu anschliessen
wird sogar wenn sie eu mitglied würde
könnten diese dinge kontrolliert werden
aber um die angst vor dem anderen vor
der zukunft zu schüren
im moment gibt es viele ängste über ich
kann verstehen dass man angst hat aber
wenn wir uns von angst lenken lassen
besteht die gefahr dass wir die gleichen
fehler machen wie unsere großeltern vor
nicht allzu langer zeit gemacht habe
deshalb müssen wir erinnerungen pflegen
nationalismus stammesdenken
fremdenfeindlichkeit fanatische dortmund
diese dinge führten in der jüngeren
weltgeschichte zu schrecklichen
erlebnissen
deshalb brauchen wir einen besseren
ansatz sowie hafte alphabet ob protsch
dann dann bis von und wenn wir sagen
narratives spielen heute eine so große
rolle dann könnte man eher sagen das ist
auch die zeit der schriftsteller und
schriftstellerinnen die verstehen sich
aufs geschichten erzählen also haben sie
das gefühl da eine spezifische
verantwortung auch zu haben
weiteres offen gesagt bin ich der
meinung dass schriftsteller deutlicher
stellung beziehen sollten wir müssen aus
unseren kokon herauskommen was nicht
einfach ist von natur aus sind wir
introvertierte menschen schriftsteller
sind sehr einsam gewesen
unsere arbeit gründet auf einsamkeit
trotzdem glaube ich wir müssen in die
öffentlichkeit müssen über politik
sprechen
als türkische schriftstellerin als
nigerianische ägyptischer oder
pakistanischer schriftsteller können sie
sich den luxus nicht leisten apolitisch
zu sein oder sie das was um sie herum
geschieht nicht kalt lässt
wir müssen uns mit politischen fragen
befassen schwierige politische fragen
stellen und zu diskussionen ermutigen
das ist sehr wichtig und ich versuche
das in meinen büchern
ich stelle schwierige fragen zur
politischen tabus sexuellen kulturellen
tabus die antworten überlasse ich aber
immer den leserinnen und leser ja
eigentlich ein bisschen wie bei ihnen
frau coleen sie haben mir im vorfeld
auch gesagt dass es interessant finde
ich eigentlich politikwissenschaftlerin
werden aber fast immer angesprochen auf
der genannte deutsch türkin ein ausdruck
den sie nicht mögen
also man muss sozusagen immer dann
gerade stehen für eine ein aspekt im
leben der ein jahres auch nicht
vollumfänglich ausmacht sondern sie sind
noch ganz viel anderes als deutsch
türkin mehr dass die last der
repräsentanz die einem da aufgebürdet
wird je nachdem in welchem kontext man
sich bewegt also bis jetzt deutsch
türkin ist oder türken oder als deutsche
in der türkei es gibt diesen türkischen
begriff manche also deutschländer
deutschländer rinnen als
erkennungsmerkmal die gehört gar nicht
so richtig dazu
das wird dann festgemacht am 18
festgemacht am habitus bewegungsformen
an den dingen die man liest das war teil
meiner jugend und kindheit wenn wir in
der türkei waren
ich mag diese zuschreibungen deshalb
nicht weil sie sehr vieles von einem
selbst und das betrifft ja nicht nur
mich persönlich absolut in den
hintergrund rücken die den menschen mich
in dem moment zusätzlich mit ausmachen
ich verstehe das als kategorisierung als
kategorisierung in schubladen die einem
sicherheit bieten die aber nichts
darüber aussagen in welchem bezug ich
selber dazu stehe oder inwiefern ich
hier ein zuhause eine heimat eine ja
vielleicht auch völlig praktikable
verwendung von staatsbürgerschaft von
zugehörigkeit verwende und es rückt
viele aspekte die mir wichtig sind im
zusammenleben im gemeinsamen
zusammenleben in dem bekenntnis zu oder
als einwanderungsgesellschaft zu einer
pluralistischen gesellschaft in den
hintergrund deswegen finde ich diese
zuschreibungen äußerst problematisch ich
verstehe dass hier gut dass sega hat
trotzdem werde ich jetzt gleich noch
einmal belasten mit der repräsentanz
last wie sie das genannt haben nämlich
sie aus frauen anzusprechen das ja auch
immer so interessant dass man als frau
dann immer noch kommentieren soll die
man jetzt trump als frau findet ich
mache es ich mache es trotzdem also die
wahl von donald trump ist natürlich auch
etwas was viele frauen aus ohrfeige
empfunden haben
wie reagieren die spezifisch darauf dass
man ja auch ein stück weit da eine
parallele ausmachen muss kann soll
zwischen präsident erdogan und trump
beispielsweise wie harfst
in many cases after in vielen
weltgegenden insbesondere auch in der
türkei haben wir konservative männliche
politiker die uns frauen von oben herab
sagen wie wir zu leben haben wie wir uns
kleiden soll
stress ab in der türkei hat man uns zum
beispiel gesagt wir sollten in der
öffentlichkeit nicht laut lachen ehrbare
türkische frauen würden das nicht tun
man hat uns gesagt wir sollten drei oder
besser fünf kinder gebären weil die
türkische nation wachsen müsse
all diese dinge werden uns von oben her
auferlegt und da reagiert meine sehen
weil sie kein richter zu haben
es geht um unsere leben unserer körper
und ich bin der festen überzeugung dass
wir eine frauenbewegung brauchen die
frauen von unterschiedlichsten
hintergründen zusammenbringt und eine
kultur der schwester lichkeit schafft
die an die gleichberechtigung der
geschlechter und an die frauenrechte
glaubt dazu gehören auch die rechte für
homosexuelle und transgender auch in
amerika sind viele frauen jetzt
schockiert weil die rechte die sie für
selbstverständlich hielten sehr schnell
abgebaut werden könnten
diese politiker sind sehr
frauenfeindlich politischen politik ganz
allgemein ist männerdominiert es gibt
unsichtbare barrieren sogar in
fortschrittlichen modernen westlichen
gesellschaften gibt es um sichtbare
gläserne decken
diese können wir nur zerschlagen wenn
wir zusammenarbeit keine frau schafft
das allein
ich unterschreibe das alles zu 100
prozent meine sorge ist einfach ist noch
nicht so lange her dass man den female
shift aufgerufen hat der megatrend
female shift frauen werden alles
übernehmen wo stehen wir hier also das
erschreckende an der wahl in den oder
ich möchte jetzt diese superlative der
der angst phänomene gar nicht mal
unbedingt verwenden dass das mich
wirklich irritiert hat mich persönlich
als frau weil sie das jetzt ansprechen
ganz konkret ist die tatsache dass wir
viele frauen im vorfeld wählerinnen
erklärt haben ich wähle tram trotz
seiner misogynie ich wähle donald trump
trotz der sexuellen belästigung et
cetera
weil es mich persönlich nicht betrifft
weil nicht ich sexuell belästigt wurde
weil nicht ich angefasst wurde also
sprich wir haben hier eine
entsolidarisierung mit sehr starke
entsolidarisierung in der einige frauen
marginalisiert werden nicht als
zugehörig erkannt werden oder als nicht
zugehörig markiert werden und sehr viele
frauen die sich von dieser form der
politik überhaupt nicht angesprochen
fühlen oder die auch nicht in einen
größeren kontext setzen können was das
in folge wahlausgangs bedeuten kann
interessant fand ich zu lesen dass
präsident erdogan 2012 ja in diesem zuge
der auch er wollte ja auch das
abtreibungsgesetz in der türkei re
formulieren und strikter machen und in
diesem zuge hat er zum beispiel solche
dinge gesagt wie seine frau hätte vier
kinder und nicht mal eine waschmaschine
und dieser spruch der könnte ebenso gut
von donald trump stammen ist er im
kontext der türkei nochmals viel
brisanter zu sehen aus in den usa als
ndr burschen de pages
ich glaube in der türkei ist die
abtreibungsdebatte sehr wichtig leider
haben 2012 die akp-regierung und erdogan
selber eine negative haltung gegenüber
den abtreibungs rechten eingenommen
sagte sogar abtreibung sei biologisch
das ist das versehentliche massaker an
34 zivilisten an kurdischen schmugglern
die die türkische armee für terroristen
hunde türkischen zuvor
er sagte damit dass jede abtreibung mit
massenmord gleichzusetzen sei oder mit
der tötung dieser 34 schmuggler
ich fand das war ein sehr unglücklicher
vergleich in diesem kontext lassen sie
mich auch noch einmal die frage stellen
wie frei können sie denn überhaupt
sprechen und wie einfach ist es für sie
in dieser ganzen kritik die sie immer
wieder formulieren heute noch in die
türkei zu reisen ist completed wickel es
kompliziert einfach weil es glaube ich
sehr kompliziert ist eine türkische
schriftstellerin zu sein
sie erhalten viel zuwendung von den
lesern das ist unglaublich ehren
gleichzeitig erhalten sie viele
hassreden beleidigungen und bei
autorinnen sind die meisten dieser
hassreden sehr sex ist ich denke für
autorinnen journalistinnen
akademikerinnen ist es viel schwieriger
wir werden immer herab gemindert es gibt
viel frauenhass nicht nur in der
gesellschaft die türkische gesellschaft
ist sehr patriotisch sehr sexistisch und
sehr homophobie aber auch der
literaturbetrieb ist sehr sexy für eine
schriftstellerin ist es deshalb etwas
schwieriger für sie müssen härter
kämpfen um respektiert zu werden geht
respekt aber gleichzeitig erhalten sie
viel zu wenn ich denke immer als
türkische schriftstellerin werden sie
gleichzeitig geküsst und geschlagen
die eine wange mit geschlagen die andere
geküsst das ist ein etwas verwirrendes
gefühl aber sie können sie können oder
könnten heute nach istanbul fliegen
natürlich kann ich gehe in die türkei
aber mein herz ist voller trauer
weil ich freunde habe schriftsteller
journalisten akademiker die inhaftiert
wurden ins gefängnis kamen die auf
schwarze listen gesetzt wurden oder im
exil leben
das stigma und diese behandlung nicht
verdient haben sie alle müssten sofort
befreit
im moment sind über 134 journalisten in
der türkei im gefängnis
das bedeutet nicht fortschritt deshalb
mache ich mir zunehmend unglaubliche
sorgen sowohl um die demokratie in der
türkei wie um die türkischen demokraten
wenn wir zurückgehen zu den frauen in
der türkei
interessant ist dass wir schon
vielleicht oder ich denke wir haben hier
ein bisschen ein einseitiges bild wir
sehen jetzt dass zunehmend die frauen
sich verhüllen müssen dass die rechte
geschnitten werden dieses
abtreibungsgesetz konnte dann verhindert
werden dass es kam nicht zu dieser
verschärfung und trotzdem gibt es die
situation der frau die sich eigentlich
immer mehr so entwickelt dass man den
eindruck hat die akp und der wahren
wollen die frau ins häusliche
zurückdrängen
aber an den universitäten sind nach wie
vor sehr viel mehr professorinnen
angestellt als in der schweiz oder in
deutschland sehr viel mehr türken sind
in führungspositionen aus beispielsweise
in der schweiz und die tür kinder hatten
schon 1934 das wahlrecht also wie kommt
es zu diesem zu diesen sagen wir jetzt
mal ein stück weit ein missverhältnis
oder müsste man sagen es beginnt sich
jetzt eben gerade das rad zurückzudrehen
und es wird sich das alles ein stück
weiter verändern
also wir erleben hier die
gleichzeitigkeit von entwicklungen und
das bedeutet dass sich diese
entwicklungen nicht ausschließen
beispielsweise das was sie jetzt zuletzt
genannt haben das hier deutlich mehr
frauen in höheren positionen arbeiten in
stellen arbeiten die lukrativ sind die
mit prestige verbunden sind schließt
eben nicht aus dass immer mehr frauen
oder ein relativ großer teil der form
vom arbeitsmarkt verdrängt werden und
das ist möglich indem eine form der
politischen kultur gewandelt wird hier
gegen frauen gewandelt wird also sprich
dass hier der fokus auf das häusliche
gelagert wird oder wie damals 2000
während der abtreibungsdebatte die sache
inhalte verquickt werden mit dem
demografischen wandel also sprich das
hier erklärt wurde
wir möchten ein komplettes
abtreibungsverbot weil wir türken immer
weniger werden also diese demografische
kaufen wir brauchen nachwuchs sprich die
frauen wurden reduziert in dieser
diskussion auf letzten endes
gebärmaschinen diese gleichzeitigkeit
entwicklungen schließt aber auch nicht
aus überhaupt nicht dass hier frauen
nach wie vor extrem präsent sind in der
öffentlichkeit sehr viele der
verhafteten der verhafteten verhafteten
in den gefängnissen sind frauen sind
journalistinnen sind wissenschaftlerin
die mit ihrer arbeit zum teil auch ihr
leben riskiert haben hier an vorderster
stelle kämpfen für mehr freiheit mehr
demokratie und auch mehr schutz für
frauen für kinder für marginalisierte
menschen also wir dürfen nicht den
fehler machen den fokus zu sehr auf den
dominanten aspekt der regierung und auch
auf den dominanten staatspräsidenten zu
lenken und alles andere was gleichzeitig
passiert innerhalb der zivilbevölkerung
gerade unter den frauen und jungen
mädchen und auch jungen frauen
auszublenden
das würde zu erkennen dass hier nach wie
vor sehr viel kraft investiert wird um
freiheitliche rechte und demokratische
rechte beizubehalten und eben gegen die
verbote vorzugehen
lassen sie nicht zum schluss bevor ich
unserem publikum das wort geben möchte
noch einmal auf ihr buch eingehen
ähnlich scharfe geruch des paradieses
ihr neuester roman
da geht es im wesentlichen um drei
figuren eine gläubige muslimin eine
artistin und peri eine junge türkin die
sich in erster linie als religiös
verwirrt erlebt ist das religiös
verwirrt sein
zeitgleich in der türkei den im grunde
genommen präsident erdogan jetzt
aufnehmen kann und wänden hin zu einem
vielleicht stückweit einem
islamistischem gedankengut
ich habe absichtlich der türkin die
rolle der verwirrten zugeschrieben weil
wir in der türkei allgemein sehr
verwirrt sind in bezug auf identität
erinnerung vergangenheit wohin wir
wollen
in der türkei gibt es viele
auseinandersetzungen darüber in
mancherlei hinsicht ist das verständlich
denn es ist ein land an einem knoten das
hat elemente vom osten und es versucht
in einer sehr schwierigen region zu
bestehen was mir aber das herz bricht
ist dass wir in der türkei
diese ganze komplexität nicht als etwas
kostbares sehen
stattdessen versuchen wir sie zu
unterdrücken alle extremistischen
ideologien weltweit
ob rechtsextremismus islamistische
fundamentalismus oder autoritarismus
haben etwas gemeinsam sie mögen keine
komplexität
sie versuchen dinge zu simplifizieren
uns auf eine einzige identität zu
reduzieren so sagen sie etwa wenn du ein
muslim bist kannst du nur muslim sein
bist du das willst du nur das während
wir menschen aus zahlreichen ich es
zusammengesetzt sind
wir bestehen aus wasser wir haben also
vielfache zugehörigkeiten wir können in
mehr als einer sprache träumen wir
dürfen nicht auf die politik einer
einzigen identität reduziert werden die
das ist was in der türkei geschieht wenn
eine politik der einen identität wird
durchgesetzt wie in vielen anderen
teilen dieser welt auch und ich
widersetze mich dem in meinen büchern
und in meinem leben ich sehe mich selbst
als jemanden der vielfache
zugehörigkeiten hat mir gefällt der
gedanke dass ich mehr als ein der heimat
mehr als ein heimatland
ich bin eine istanbuler rinn ich habe
auch bindungen zum balkan zuerst
mittelmeer zum nahen osten
ich bin eine wahl europäerin und eine
weltbürgerin mit meiner arbeit versuche
ich wieder komplexität und nuancen in
die diskussion zurück zu bringen
das erinnert mich eigentlich gerade an
die lektüre von carolin im cas buch über
den hass die eigentlich genau dafür
plädiert komplexität auszuhalten und
sich eine genauigkeit zu leisten in der
analyse und eben nicht alles zu
verflachen platt zu walzen so dass dann
nur noch die groben konturen irgendwie
sichtbar werden und eben auch alles
verdreht und verzerrt wird
in dieser einfachheit aber jetzt sind
sie an der reihe ihre fragen ihre
kommentare würden hier sehr gerne hören
bitte melden sie sich gerne wenn sie
mitdiskutieren möchte ich schon lange
beschäftigt ist wie kann man
veränderungsprozesse hin zu einer
vielfältigen gesellschaft nachhaltiger
gestalten was können wir tun
als frauen als schweizerinnen als
europäer
wichtig ist hier dass der aspekt der
solidarität in den vordergrund tritt
trotz differenzen
trotz beispielsweise politischer
differenzen oder religiöser differenzen
also wenn wir aus einer familie spektive
denken dann eben über den aspekt der
intersexualität hier solidarität
miteinander zu zeigen zu beweisen und
einander nicht zu vergessen sei
schockiert dass es mal eine kleine
ergänzung von hinten nicht nur in der
türkei im ganzen nahen osten gibt es
einen systematischen rückschlag was
frauen und frauenrechte betrifft wenn
sie im nahen osten reisen stellen sie
fest dass die straßen den männern
gehören öffentliche plätze gehören den
männern insbesondere nach einbruch der
dunkelheit gehören die städte den
männern und frauen werden systematisch
in die häuser in den privaten raum
zurückgestoßen und man sagt uns dass
unsere erste rolle mutterschaft zeit
müssen wir uns wieder setzen das geht
nur gemeinsam
meiner meinung nach brauchen wir in der
türkei im nahen osten eine alles
umfassende frauenbewegung und gibt dann
die miete eine frage guten abend mich
würde interessieren ob diese bald
maschine erdogan dazu führt dass diese
demokratische identität in der türkei
stärker wird oder eher schwächer ich
denke dass die demokratischen kräfte die
bereits vorhanden sind und bereits
vorhanden waren deutlich mehr an kraft
gewinnen können das ja auch eine chance
legt viel problematischer ist der aspekt
der angst politik also sprich dass die
menschen untereinander und voreinander
angst haben wie beispielsweise an der
universität erlebt in der türkei wo ein
student ein seminar mit aufnahmen über
das smartphone mit dieser aufnahme zum
dekan gegen und die entsprechende
professorin oder ihr gekündigt worden
ist ohne dass hier ein gespräch gesucht
wurde und ohne dass hier der studierende
in die grenzen verwiesen wurde und diese
beispiele häufen sich sehr stark kann
man liegend mit fakten über stimmen oder
kann man gerade wenn man an trump oder
andere populistische parolen denkt die
ja sehr sehr gezielt auf minderheiten
gerichtet sind kann man dann mit fakten
den endgegnern und wenn ja wie die
rechtsaußen populisten sprechen
emotionen an er als die vernunft wissen
während intellektuelle versuchen dinge
mit begründungen zu erklären
sie sagen nein schaut euch die fakten an
die statistiken es ist nicht so dass
aber das reicht nicht die kata team weil
wir menschen stark emotionale wesen sind
in der türkei sagt man frauen seien
emotional
das stimmt nicht
männer und frauen wir alle sind
emotionale wesen deshalb müssen wir eine
sprache entwickeln die gleichzeitig die
herzen wie auch das denken der menschen
erreicht wir müssen einzig die bedeutung
von emotionen verstehen und diese in
unser narrativ zurückbringen but in the
pictures in tal nahe dass ich denke
nicht dass die post faktizität oder die
beschreibung der entwicklungen als post
faktisch als absolut angesehen werden
müssen oder sollten das ist das eine das
andere ist dass hier tatsächlich ein
defizit besteht an der erzählung an dem
narrativ von visionen und das ist etwas
das so genannte populistische parteien
deutlich besser bisher umgesetzt haben
besser konnten als etablierte parteien
vielleicht sogar aber das würde ich
nicht mehr ganz so klar benennen wenn
ihr auf griechenland gucken vielleicht
sogar aus dem linken spektrum eben diese
visionen fehlten
ich glaube weil wir im zeitalter der
information leben information verbreitet
sich so einfach machen wir manchmal den
fehler dass wir informationen mit wissen
verwechseln und wissen weisheit aber das
sind drei komplett verschiedene dinge
was geschieht ist dass wir viele
informationen über alles haben wir
wissen aber sehr wenig und haben sogar
noch weniger beisheim für weisheit
glaube ich brauchen wir emotionale
intelligenz in diesem zusammenhang sind
emotionen sehr wichtig ich finde für uns
ist es unglaublich wichtig emotionen
zurückzuholen aber auch geschichten alle
extremistischen ideologien and
menschlichen den anderen dann können sie
einen anderen menschen unterdrücken erst
wenn sie aufhören
andere person als menschliches wesen
wahrzunehmen wenn sie sie and
menschliche aber geschichten von
menschlichen weil sie uns in erinnerung
rufen dass der andere genauso ist wie
ich ihre sorgen sind meine sorgen ihre
freuden sind sehr ähnlichem eine die
anderen sind also so wie ich geschichten
machen den anderen wieder zum menschen
deshalb finde ich dass sie immer zum
gespräch gehört in meine frage richte
sich an wie sie wissen läuft heutzutage
einen showdown zwischen der türkei und
der eu
was denken sie über die aktuelle
situation sollte die türkei in die eu
kann die türkei teil der eu seien oder
nicht ist bewusst dass die eu
mitgliedschaft der türkei im moment
wenig wahrscheinlich scheint und es gibt
nicht viele leute die glauben dass es je
soweit kommt weder in europa noch in der
türkei
ich gehöre aber zu jenen die die eu
mitgliedschaft der türkei unterstützen
ob schon die chance sehr klein gerade
deshalb finde ich sollten wir die
hoffnung lebendig erhalten diese flamme
am leben erhalten weil andernfalls wenn
die türkei isoliert wird das nur den
interessen der isolationisten dient wer
sind diese isolationisten türkischer
ultranationalisten und religiöse
konservative die sind sehr glücklich
wenn die türkei von europa weg drückt
und ich will nichts dass die türkische
jugend mit dem gedanken auf wächst das
für die türkei eine anlehnung an
russland die einzige alternative sein
oder eine anlehnung an pakistan oder so
zu sein wie der iran oder wie saudi
arabien
ich will nicht dass mein heimatland wie
russland ist oder wie saudi arabien
es ist wichtig seine demokratie zu
ermutigen
wir haben in einem interview gesagt
forscher [ __ ] in der türkei vergeht die
zeit nicht sie galoppiert warum
weil man das gefühl hat dass jeden tag
jede woche etwas geschieht und fast
keine zeit bleibt anzuhalten
nachzudenken zu analysieren
sogar nach den schrecklichen
bombenattentaten terrorattacken gab es
praktisch keine zeit zu trauern
wir können uns nicht einmal in unserer
trauer vereinen weil in der folgenden
woche etwas neues geschickt und die
woche darauf wieder
wir haben ständig das gefühl dass wir
von einem ereignis ins nächste
katapultiert werden
manchmal wünsche ich mir dass wir in der
türkei dieses tempobremsen lasst uns
miteinander reden und beruhigen es gibt
viel wut und ich glaube nicht dass wut
hilft deshalb brauchen wir im
öffentlichen raum mehr frauen und wir
brauchen ruhe auch bei uns sich die zeit
galoppiert wir sind am ende unserer
sendezeit bedanke mich ganz herzlich
dass sie meine gäste hier waren frau
scharf mag vielen herzlichen dank frau
kohler schatten ganz herzlichen dank
ihnen allen vielen dank für interesse
vielen dank dass sie nach region ans gdi
gekommen sind mit uns diskutiert haben
danke ihnen fürs interesse auch nächste
woche gibt es natürlich wieder
sternstunden und zwar mit einer weiteren
ausgabe des philosophischen stammtisch
unter anderen diskutieren wir die
bewegung des effektiven autor ist es die
uns dazu auffordert möglichst viel gutes
zu tun
auch mit unserem geld das ihr den besten
hilfswerken spenden sollen fragt sich
bloß hilft spenden wirklich und so wie
viel verzicht sind sie und ich
verpflichtet war sie fragen dazu haben
oder eine fixe meinung schreiben sie mir
an philosophie at&s punkt ch ich freue
mich auf ihre zuschriften bis nächste
woche also und jetzt einen schönen
sonntag
[Applaus]
[Musik]